so Jocelyn welcome thank you very much
why don't you tell us start out by
telling us a little bit about your
career path from Stanford student to a
director of engineering at Facebook boy
I could probably spend the entire
lecture just answering this question
well when I was a student I really had
absolutely no idea what I wanted to do
when I grew up and I majored in computer
science because I loved programming I
loved the logic and the sort of
analytical nature of it but I didn't
really have like a super clear idea of
what being a software engineer was like
even after multiple summer internships
and so I joined straight out of college
I joined a company called trilogy that
was based in austin texas mainly because
trilogy had a very different recruiting
pitch than a lot of the other big
software companies most of the software
companies were saying things like well
you know come work for us and just make
software and trilogy was like well come
work for us and do a little of this and
a little of that and will expose you to
a lot of things and so I went and it was
kind of true is a very chaotic company
but I made great friends and and just
was sort of put in situation's where it
was a very entrepreneurial environment
actually because you just kind of had to
figure out what the boom and deliver and
sort of not know any boundaries there
was not you know a lot of structure or
processes to follow you just had to
figure out what to do to succeed and I
made great friends there including three
with whom I went on to co-found to start
up which was again I wrote code I tested
the code I wrote documentation I
supported the customers i deployed the
software did everything I hired people I
hired the front office manager I stocked
the fridge so it was really terrific and
somewhere in there I also started
managing people and I found that when I
was managing engineers it sort of
finally plugged in for me that this was
actually my right career path because
I've been always fascinated by people as
well as by technology i was actually a
minor in symbolic systems Toby winograd
was my advisor concentrated in HCI and
so I was taking tons of psychology and
linguistics classes at Stanford you want
to blow your mind take a linguistics
class the same class you take the same
quarter you take compilers like and you
will find you were studying the same
thing but from different sides
and so and so being a manager I found
was a lot about social engineering and
it was a lot about understanding what
made people tick and what made teams
tick and and and and there was just
really interesting difficult structural
and systems problems to solve of the
human kind as well as of the technology
kind so it was like yes at last like
every neuron in my brain is firing and
I'm also just motivated to bring my A
game by other people by my teammates by
my colleagues the reason founding a
start-up was amazing was because you
know i was working 120 hour weeks i was
working with crazy town but i was
thrilled every minute because i was
coming through for my team and they were
coming through for me the startup though
did reach sort of a point where we were
doing a major strategic pivot and i was
ready to move on and i was ready to come
back to Silicon Valley my I also married
a Stanford grad we were and a another
computer science major and and he and I
had kind of made this pact that we would
be in austin for no more than two to
four years that was to stanford CS grads
who were obviously destined to be based
in Silicon Valley we had been in texas
for over five years at this point what
would the startup and so we decided to
come back to california and in
california i ran into a really good
friend of mine from school jeremy
Sugarman who who had joined a startup
founded by one of our professors by my
OS professor actually Mendel and it was
called VMware and Jeremy had I tried to
hire Jeremy for my company he wouldn't
come he went to Mendel's company instead
and so this was a couple years later
VMware was now 350 people still pretty
small I'd only pulled an a-minus in the
OS class I had been doing nothing
related to operating system since but I
said what the heck I went in to meet
VMware the recruiter told me boy if I
had found your resume on my own like I
would have thrown it in the then the
trash can basically because you've no
operating systems experience and that's
what I've been told to look for but on
Jeremy's recommendation they talked to
me and we just clicked so joining VMware
as a manager I dusted off my operating
systems textbook and remembered what
scatter gather was all about and and in
my joint VMware I kind of got on a
rocket VMware does not have maybe the
consumer brand sex appeal of a facebook
or google but they absolutely were
doubling revenue and head
every year and they proceeded to do that
for 45 years in a row so I joined in
2003 when it was 350 people I'm gonna
left in 2010 it was over 10,000 and and
I really grew up with VMware and I still
had that same quality of wanting to come
through for my team and of taking no
prisoners of like really just wanting to
have the most impact I could have and
something that was really exciting about
being at VMware was our customers were
all geeks and they loved us they love
VMware we were transformative for what
they were trying to do it was like
science fiction because they could solve
problems they couldn't solve without us
and so that was just an amazing feeling
that we were building something that was
changing how people worked and making
their lives better but as as vmware grew
to over 10,000 people I guess my career
roast I should talk about the fact that
when i joined vmware as a manager and I
left as a vice president but I never
really thought you know there was never
a moment where I walked into my boss's
office and said where's my next
promotion coming from I was always just
thinking about how do I have the most
impact I can have on the company on my
team on our on our users and and I think
that by just trying to to have impact my
career kind of took care of me and and
and so it was I never really thought of
myself as consciously managing my career
but I left I left vm we're finally when
it was over 10,000 people and I decided
I was ready for another really big shift
and I wanted to make the jump from
enterprise to consumer and where better
to discover consumer than Facebook and
actually originally planned to go to a
very small company and I was not looking
to join a company even then Facebook was
almost 2,000 people I'd never
voluntarily joined a company that big I
had joined companies that were a few
hundred people are started my own and
and so really kind of just talked to
Facebook as a you know really kind of a
just to get aware to learn more about
the space and Facebook's head of
engineering my trefor was a classmate of
mine from Stanford to his fellow 97 grad
fellow section lead to and and so we had
lunch and I just kept talking to
startups around the valley and I kept
talking to facebook
I you know go sleep at night and I were
talking to her with my husband and
Facebook had more of the qualities of a
startup that I was looking for than the
small startups I was talking to and
there was no question after I met him
that Mark Zuckerberg was by far the most
impressive founder of all the founders I
met which is sort of at right thing to
say in hindsight like that's sort of it
uh but but but mark was amazing and and
Facebook had the culture of of startup
and so you know I gritted my teeth and
said well this doesn't match any of the
it doesn't check any of the boxes I said
I had other than consumer but what the
heck this is clearly what I want to do
in my gut so I went to Facebook I've
been there three years I've had an
amazing amazing run I've gotten to work
on really just great products that I use
every day photos newsfeed now our mobile
platform so I couldn't be happier so
let's drill down he said the culture of
Facebook was a was amazing and walked in
and it felt so comfortable when you
paint a picture of the culture of
Facebook I mean you know imagine we're
all visiting what would we yes we
experience you would experience
unfinished ceilings concrete floors
Dusk's everywhere no offices not even
mark has an office and writing all over
the walls and in posters and the end and
and you would see company slogans like
this journey is one percent finished or
move fast and break things or fail
harder and facebook facebook was born
out of disruption and was born out of
trying things and seeing what happened
and it not working out and trying again
and trying harder and never being never
being daunted by failure doesn't mean we
set out to fail it just means like we're
not afraid of it and we're willing to
keep taking risks and the entire
environment is meant to keep you from
feeling complacent or or comfortable or
like we've we've won we never want to
feel like we've won we always want to
feel pretty hungry and like somebody
could come in our lunch tomorrow because
somebody could and and we never want to
take it for granted we want and and so
for its it's the most humble successful
company I've ever known
and it may sound strange to say that
that Facebook is a humble company but it
really is we really don't take a success
for granted and we think that our users
are choosing to be there and they could
just as easily choose not to be there if
we don't deliver a great service I love
the fact that the first thing you said
when I asked you to describe the culture
was described the space yes now it's
something we spend a lot of time
thinking about in the classes I teach on
creativity and certainly we're in this
really remarkable space here at Stanford
how important is the space to the
culture there and I know I've spent time
at Facebook and its really interesting
especially with the new buildings now
what sort of things did people think
about in creating this of the space oh
it's very deliberate it's absolutely
deliberate I culture you cannot just
think of the culture you want and then
create it you've culture arises from so
many small things someone actually a
Stanford professor I wish I could
remember his name but from the business
school once said something that really
stuck with me which is culture is the
behaviors that you reward and punish at
the end of the day people look around
and they mimic the behaviors that they
think will be successful and they try to
avoid the behaviors to think will be
unsuccessful I think that's really true
actually and deeply true but you've also
got to try to show people what behaviors
you want and and what behaviors you you
don't want and the space is one of those
things that just sort of sneaks right
past all your sort of human defenses and
cynicism and processing and it just goes
straight to the hindbrain and tells you
and you understand it on a gut level
like when you walk on those concrete
floors you know oh we're not finished
we're not luxurious we're not taking it
for granted like we're scrappy and the
open space is another huge one you guys
are all I think many of you are probably
computer science majors hopefully you've
all taken 106 if not take 106 before you
leave Stanford best opportunity of a
lifetime and you know if you've
programmed it like you need focused
attention right you need flow time you
need and you know that even small
interruptions like it takes you a long
time to get back into the stream of
thing so you and so the idea of having
programmers sit out in open space at
opened desks with desks all around them
and talking in conversation in foot
traffic that's controversial for many
years it was the the gold standard in
Silicon Valley was to have offices
engineers are housed in offices
preferably a single office sometimes two
people per office that's what VMware did
and when we took over the campus from
sanh it was all offices we told the we
told the builders to actually start by
knocking down every wall that wasn't
structural and make as big an empty
space in the building's as we could and
then we'd sort of fill it in from there
and why why was it so important to us
that we would actually sacrifice
engineer productivity which is what
we're doing have everybody out in the
open space like that it's not density
it's not to save money well it's because
one of the key values of facebook is be
open it's what the product is for the
product is for sharing a communication
that's also really fundamental to our
DNA as a culture too it's actually that
we expect every individual to be
informed and in the know about what's
going on and that empowers you to make
good decisions and so we sort of set the
expectation that everything's out in the
open everybody's plugged in everybody's
aware of what's going on and then we put
headphones in the vending machines and
try to create lots of private spaces
where people can hide and give everybody
a laptop and have a pretty loose work
from home policy so we do everything we
can to mitigate the the productivity
impacted that openness but ultimately
every time we have to choose we choose
openness so what is the onboarding
process I mean somebody gets hired yes
and you can't just plug anyone right
into this type of culture what happens
to take a normal person off the street
plug them in and they become a facebook
employee we call it boot camp literally
it is a six-week onboarding program and
in boot camp and everybody goes into it
I was a VP of engineering at VMware I
had not written code in seven years when
I got to Facebook they said here's your
desk here's your laptop here's your unix
account and here's five bugs that are
assigned to you to fix and you spend
your first six weeks at Facebook fixing
bugs and implementing small teacher
features all of the site and in
attending lectures you have a boot camp
mentor who is a full-time software
engineer whose job is to help you
they'll help you get code reviews
they'll help you figure out what task to
work on and at the end of the six weeks
they'll help you find a team and I think
that boot camp is so is such a good
program for so many reasons I actually
give one of the onboarding I actually
give Facebook's introduction to culture
for boot campers and one of the many
great things boot camp does is it builds
empathy before you
if I with a particular team you identify
with Facebook and you fix code and every
even if you walk in determined to do you
know back-end services will make you
write some web code will make you fix an
issue on mobile no matter what you're
going to do we're going to give you at
least the tools to inspect to
investigate to know about what's going
on in other parts of the world and it
really sends the message we want to send
which is everything connects all
engineers are connected to one another
the facebook employees is just another
subset of the social graph and so in
boot camp you hook up your social graph
to your first set of co-workers who then
spread out to the four corners of
engineering and give you connections in
every part of the company but you know a
little bit of something about everything
after boot camp and and that's an
incredible asset for a new hire so for
six weeks you were just doing bootcamp
mm-hmm that's right so what are you
looking for when people are coming to
interview I know that the standards are
incredibly high and it's one of the most
attractive places to work in the world
how porn is technical skills as well as
other things like creativity and being
able to work on teams yeah what are you
looking for the number one thing we're
looking for in hiring a software
engineer is the ability to write code
and is the ability to reason and to be
analytical and to find mistakes and fix
them quickly and to analyze the running
time so that when you're later on
building systems you know you
demonstrate that you have the potential
to think about hard systems issues if
you are a new grad frankly that's the
primary thing is that ability to write
code we also want to make sure that
you're not a jerk we definitely like
want people at Facebook who are nice and
we will reject people who have great
coding skills just because they seem
like they would be appalling to work
with but we want people who have
enthusiasm who have a fire in their
belly who are not going to take no for
an answer we want people who are not
going to be afraid we want people who
are going to attack making software with
gusto and and we are looking for
creativity so so we we've actually we've
met 'old with the we've meddled with the
interview process a lot I've actually
personally hacked on our interview
process Allah another reason you find so
much graffiti on the walls at Facebook
actually we invite our employees to
write on the walls is because we want
people to feel like if there's something
at Facebook that you don't
like or that you think should be
different like pop open the hood like
the cement is never dry you can you can
mess with it you can change it and I've
missed with our interview process and
one of the things that I did is I
noticed one thing that made engineers
really successful at Facebook was when
they had just really good intuition for
what would be a good feature or a good
product we obviously have designers and
product managers that we work with but
the way we work is so iterative like we
try things we test them we try something
else we test them and so the difference
between a good intuition and just trying
things and testing them you know you
might try three things or try ten things
right and save months if you just have
great intuition and so we started
interviewing consciously interviewing
for that and we won't hire you on
intuition alone if you're not also a
great coder where we might in product
management but we wouldn't in a software
engineer but it turns out to be
something that distinguishes good from
great software engineers so we started
interviewing for that so obviously we
all know about Sheryl Sandberg's book
leaning okay and I want to ask you just
between you and me mmm is facebook
culture designed to be supportive of
women really i don't think it's designed
in that way but i think it is supportive
to women and i think that it's
supportive to women because everything
happens out in the open like everybody
is talking live you see how decisions
get made there's no sort of secret back
room and and so there's not a what I
want to say hey it's I don't know I I
don't know I can't say I've ever worked
in an environment that I found super
unfriendly to women so it's hard to
contrast but I just feel like at
Facebook we're having the conversation
much more and we're also like going out
of our way to structure relationships
and social bonds between the women in
engineering like we're talking about it
and I think that's partly because Cheryl
is there and is writing books like lean
in or giving her TED talk but but you
know we're vocal about it we have a
great community of technical a minute at
Facebook who are sort of and and the
range of opinions you know span widely
because women aren't all the same so
one of the things like men are always
coming really like what should we do to
make Facebook more friendly to women I'm
like well you know that I devastated to
tell you that women don't all want the
same thing we are not all like empty
friendly to women does not mean any one
thing but I you know I think it is
fundamentally a meritocratic environment
it's an eye it's a it's an environment
where ideas when it's an idea where it's
an environment where code winds are
arguments and yeah I found it an
extremely great but probably the best
thing about it just is the fact that we
are so open about having this
conversation and and it's so welcome to
talk about it whereas I think it was a
little bit it's just kind of taboo in a
lot of places you just is just you don't
talk about it if you bring it up you're
a whiner right and it facebook like we
talked about everything so have you
personally made any choices that have
allowed you to have a very intense
professional career and also to have a
family have I made choices well how
about has her family made choices and um
well I think I just the best choice I
made by far I didn't even know I was
making and that was who I married I
mentioned I married a fellow fellow alum
and and my husband has been incredibly
supportive of my career and and after we
had our second child he actually made
the decision to be a stay-at-home dad
and the fact that he is home with our
kids really does enable it brings a
dance to our lives and it allows me to
hit it that much harder in the office in
the workplace but I think another choice
I made you know coming back from Texas
to California when we did part of the
reasoning for that was because we were
also starting to think about having kids
and I thought you know if we have kids I
want to be near my mom and my mom
happens to be here in Palo Alto and so
in some ways just dumb luck that I have
you know that I happened to marry a guy
who is going to be willing to be a
full-time parent that I happen to have
my mom living in a location that was
like the best place in the world for my
career to be so I do you feel like I won
the lottery multiple times let me be
clear but but that support that I've had
from my mom from my husband definitely
you know I mean
women make it work I know a woman who's
also a vp of engineering at vmware who's
a single mom of three in cambridge
massachusetts and i'm in awe of her but
i think that my path has definitely been
easier because of the support I've had
so is there other advice you would give
to young people who are looking ahead I
mean this is often a discussion I have
with my students they're really
struggling to figure out how to how to
have it all yes you know how do I end up
having a challenging career you know
wonderful friendships have a family it
all feels like these are full-time jobs
yeah I mean I mean I will tell you what
i did i mean i think i did luck out in
and who I married but I think you should
absolutely be looking to marry someone
who's supportive of your career who
believes in your career and who is going
to be supportive of the home life
because it does take two people i think
you should hate housework I hate
housework actually and and I can't tell
you the number and I seriously and you
are a computer science major from
Stanford you're earning power is
incredible an hour of your time is so
valuable you can pay someone to do the
dishes in the laundry we do not because
my husband is psycho and doesn't want
help in the house and so he does the
dishes in laundry but that's the deal
like I would pay someone to do it if it
were my job so so I you know I can't say
how many women I know who are who share
my husband's use that they don't want
household help and I think that why like
the things in my life like I love my job
like you should pursue work that you
love that you're passionate about
because otherwise it's not worth it as a
trade-off and you should have a family
if you're excited about having a family
and like those things that you should be
passionate out and then you should just
like ruthlessly eliminate from your life
time spent on things that you're not
passionate about whether that's like
I've always chosen to live close to work
so I have the shortest possible commute
time in the car is bedtime and you know
and i outsource housework if my husband
didn't want to be doing the housework I
would be paying someone to do it you
know I just think that like if you want
all the great stuff and then then you
know be ruthless about not wasting your
time on stuff that doesn't matter
in-house what really doesn't matter so
let's let's go back to your culture or
Facebook yeah I love the fact that
they're all these mottos around yeah
move fast break thing yes okay what
happens if you really break something I
mean it's really nice to happen it on a
nice poster around yes you know but what
give me can you tell us some stories
about some things that have actually
broken and what's happened because we
all know that people are watching as you
said it's kind of like a big game and
the incentives are there and people see
what happens if someone sees that
someone does something and it hasn't
turned out and they get punished they're
not going to take a risk so can you give
us some examples so I think that was
just a poster on the wall for me until I
broke something big myself so I'll tell
that story this was when I was in boot
camp it was week 5 and so it's brand new
to the company nobody knew me from Adam
and I noticed that my first few weeks in
boot camp I was assigned a bunch of bugs
to fix and it turned out that like three
out of the five were obsolete someone
had already fixed them or the coded
gonna be factored and just didn't wasn't
an issue anymore and so I realized that
there were actually a lot of bugs in the
bug database that were kind of they were
crushed basically and if you like bugs
don't sound like a very sexy thing but
if you are determined ship high-quality
software one of the things you need is
information about what is your state
like what is the state of my software
and a bug database can be a faithful
representation of the state of the world
if you are really scrupulous about your
bug hygiene and about closing out bugs
that about triaging your bag it's about
looking at every bug and about closing
out the ones that aren't relevant
including ones that exist but you're
never going to do anything about because
they don't matter and and so at vmware i
had built a name for myself by being
like this monstrous treasure of bugs
like I triage probably had a thousand
bugs in my first month of VMware and and
you know at Facebook I was walking into
a much more mature environment that
already you know had a lot of bugs open
and I or C had sort of reflection in
hindsight that it's just not what I did
it via more didn't really work for me
but it also was incredibly skillful and
so I wanted to try something new I
wanted to try automating bug triage in a
way and writing a script that would
essentially if a bug had been untouched
for three months at Facebook things move
so fast if something's been untouched
for three months that's a pretty good
sign that it's
and so after three months it would sort
of just post an update to the bug saying
hey does is this thing still relevant or
can you close it out and that would
trigger an email to everybody see see it
on the bug and then if another three
months went by and nobody responded to
that or updated the issue then it would
just autumn auto close it so I was
building this i call it the task reaper
and and i was writing this script and i
was testing it and i wasn't careful
enough in my testing and i accidentally
just was moving some code around was
copy paste error and i moved something
out of an if block and probably guessing
where this is going i accidentally ran
the test on live data and it pained
14,000 bugs because the first time you
run this there's a lot of untouched bugs
it pinged 14,000 bugs and that means it
generated email to everybody on the CC
list of all the 14,000 bugs which meant
i basically launched it an isle of
service attack on our email info so this
brought in the bug system to sneeze but
it also brought email to its knees for
the whole company which is like a pretty
big deal i mean it doesn't take the site
down for users but it means like our
sales team can interact with customers
like engineers aren't I can't do code
review is like you know emails kind of
the lifeblood of the company even more
so in those days we used Facebook itself
more for communication now and so I was
just kind of blankly terrified like what
have I done and I really expected to be
tarred and feathered for this and there
was definitely a vocal company you know
response to what just happened to me why
do I have 200 emails from the task
creeper um but what was what was really
visible to me two things we really
striking to me one was the exchange team
and the bug tools team like the people I
expected to be most mad at me actually
just sort of roll up their sleeves
waited in and started fixing the problem
they spun up another process to process
the emails faster they threw extra
capacity on to the servers like they
just got in the trenches and they had my
back and I was a stranger they didn't
know me like they didn't like I had no
right to be messing with their systems
they just had it and then on the flip
side the communication from the company
there was no one saying how dare you
you're a new this you didn't why didn't
you ask permission nobody said that
people were saying what was the point of
this and they were saying could you
maybe send a digest email and
that of you know an email for each one
and and it you know and there would be
like but no one acted like I didn't have
the right to try like they clearly
didn't like the result that their email
is done but they didn't act like I
shouldn't try and it was like a light
bulb went on in my head I realized oh my
god this is what lets this company still
innovate even when it's already at that
time it had just passed half a billion
monthly users and like if any company
like it was just successful I'm like
what is why does facebook still have
appetite to mess with this thing that is
so successful why do we launch like you
know complete redesigns of the home page
when the home page is already the most
trafficked piece of property on the web
and and I sort of got it in that moment
it was because we are willing to take
risks we are willing to face up to the
consequences of failure if it was in the
spirit of trying for something of trying
to innovate so that was just like an
amazing experience for me and I think
you know it's not that you know you can
come to facebook and like being
competent or do things wrong all the
time I mean I think we you know there's
a lot of feedback and actions if that if
that's happening but we we view it as
every employees right to try things to
take risks and and we expect you to deal
with the consequences of your of your
failures but we also rally and help you
and have your back when you fail and and
we expect you to rally and have our
backs when we fail so it's it was it was
kind of magical introduction hi Harry
how long had you been there when this
happened five weeks five okay great
thank you so I guess we've now had
opportunities for other people who work
for you we make similar sorts of errors
yes yes aren't all them this story yeah
it makes them feel better yeah does it
make people want to try more things I
mean do you find that there is a
boldness then comes from seeing that yes
type of yes oh I really think so I mean
writing be bold on the wall is one thing
I think that's helpful but like actually
seeing that you can try things and have
them that work out and then still thrive
definitely contributes I what I tell
boot campers in my onboarding is listen
innovative ideas but by definition look
like bad ideas if they looked like good
ideas they would be obvious ideas and so
to be innovate
to be unhappy pull the courage to try
dumb ideas especially because for
something like what's your expected
success rate I mean if you're a VC
you're going to fund 10 companies hoping
that one of them will be a huge success
and the other nine may not but but
that's a great portfolio strategy right
you'd rather fund 10 companies trying
bold things with the outcome that one of
them you know is 20-fold successful then
do 10 kind of incremental easy things
and if you're a company you actually
have exactly the same calculus as a
company you would rather be trying 10
things and having nine of them fail in
1b 20-fold success like that's just good
ROI for anybody who owns the portfolio
the problem is it's bad ROI for the
actual individuals on the nine things
that failed and if you're a human being
I really think the biggest thing that
kills innovation is not you know that
companies suddenly wake up one day and
say oh I don't want to innovate right
like companies all want to innovate they
want their employees to be bold and try
risky things the problem is innovative
ideas are going to fail at that pretty
high rate and if you're a human you hate
failure you are going to try something
like the task Reaper have a horrible
experience and not try it again maybe if
you have exceptional grit you'll try two
things that feel but you should be
willing to write try ten things in a row
that fail if you're going to be a
successful entrepreneur and I do you
think that's what distinguishes
successful entrepreneurs is that
particular brand of insanity that is
ready to keep trying and keep trying in
spite of failure and keep believing in
yourself but ordinary humans do not and
so I think that you just have to provide
incredible cultural back pressure to
support people in that instance of
failure if you want them to keep trying
crazy ideas that's terrific so let's
imagine that you are flashing back in
time and you're now a student here at
Stanford again what advice do you wish
hit someone had given you I mean imagine
you were sitting in the audience
watching someone who was in a position
that the director of engineering at a
really impressive company what things do
wish they had told you that would have
had an influence both on your career
path but also on your mindset set a hard
question
um what advice what I've given myself
I think that you know you hear this all
the time but beep be brave like the
world is your oyster like you really
don't have any bad choices right now you
cannot go wrong now's the time in your
life to take a lot of risks I think that
I would have said don't I wouldn't have
listened but I would have said don't
worry about what you're going to be when
you grow up just be and it will come and
find you yeah you know I feel like you
know when I was in high school and
college so many people were like follow
your passion and follow your dream and I
was like how do I find my passion why
don't you know how do I sigh like no one
no one had particularly good advice for
what to do to figure out what you're
passionate about and so I would say it's
okay not to know just keep trying things
and you will find stuff that you are
passionate about and excited about I
would have told myself not to be afraid
of writing code for a living I was
afraid of that I was afraid that other
people would be better at it than me I
was afraid that I would be buried in
detail and not get to be strategic and
above the fray and I learned over time
that writing code is actually one of the
most strategic things you can do and
every time I meet a college student who
wants to skip being a software engineer
and go straight into product management
I'm like oh you know it's not that you
won't someday want to do those things
want to be a manager or a product
manager or designer but but you learn so
much from writing code that that that
the devil is truly in the details the
the what is possible to what is feasible
the the systems thinking just embrace it
relish it you may or may not you may
love it so much that you do it forever
you may not do it forever but every
minute you spend coding is going to make
you a thousand times better at being a
manager or a product manager or anything
else you know that is bet your time is
better spent even if your goal is to do
something else your time is better spent
writing code as preparation for it if
you want any career in software any
career
even CEO or sales or whatever it is so I
would not have been so anxious to sort
of figure out what was after software
engineering I would have spent just I
would have lived more in the now I guess
or I would advise myself to live more in
the now I would have had trouble taking
that advice well that seems like a great
segue to open up the questions to the
audience so who would like to start
great how the bat wilted and we fail
you're encouraging innovation but
where'd you guys with a draw the line
between know when okay great job you're
doing bold things you made some mistakes
but that's fine versus like this is
terrible like you need to stop doing
this how do you guys English between us
because it's that play a gray area my um
the question is where do you draw the
line it's one thing to say you know you
encourage people to fail but where do
you say okay this is too much dial it
back um so i think that uh first of all
there's some bright lines I mean there
there are things like ethical violations
that will just get you walked out the
door right so there are certain failures
that are not I tried something
innovative and it didn't work out but
that are just like I did something wrong
that are just wrong so I think that when
we when we think about sort of booing
people in the event of failure we
definitely think about helping them
solve the problem we try to actually
encourage people to feel fast right like
we don't want you to spend like it's
it's terrible to spend a year developing
a product and it's the wrong product
it's much better if you spend a week or
even a night at a hackathon throw a
prototype together and we can see on
face value hey this is not great like
let's course-correct let's try something
else I think if the failures you know a
some of it is repetition to write if you
make the same mistake over and over
again like that's just a problem right
if you're bringing the site down because
of a careless error that again wasn't
because you've had an idea and and
didn't like even Meyer was not like that
the task Reaper was a bad idea my error
was like I failed at execution right
like I made a mistake and how I was
testing it if somebody was making that
same error
over and over and over again and wasn't
learning each time right that like like
his feedback loops also write like you
learn and grow by doing stuff and seeing
what happens and taking the information
and then trying it differently the next
time like life is iteration life is
spirals upwards and and so you got to be
making different mistakes each time not
just repeating the same failure over and
over again that's right yes your
absolute a very successful manager at
VMware despite a ninja manager then
going back not being an engineer you
have and you'll save the benefit of time
so where do you feel you actually won
your challenge most suited first manager
/ twittering site and if Facebook once
promoted being manager do you go there
well I am a manager at Facebook I so so
as a manager I spent the first six weeks
in boot camp just everybody does that
but I mostly manage at Facebook but I I
will say oh and I failed to repeat the
question the question was is your time
better spent as a manager or as an
engineer and how do you decide I will
say that at VMware at the end so I was
always in the engineering department and
and I and I roast a head of engineering
and then in the last year and a half at
VMware we decided we were gonna have a
business unit structure and so I became
the general manager of desktop business
unit instead of just the vice president
of desktop engineering and being a
general manager meant that in addition
to managing engineers I also managed
product managers marketing people I
owned a PNL and I visited lots of
customers to help sell our products who
are buying desktop products and one
thing I learned from that experience is
I love building stuff for customers and
talking to customers I don't love
selling to customers and I consider
myself a good manager and I think I can
manage people who aren't engineers but
at the end of the day engineers are my
people and I love managing engineers
better than managing marketing people
and because i think at heart i want to
make stuff i want to create things
that's just my what drives me and even
as a manager I want to make teams that
make stuff and so and so that's what I
love to do the most
back there yes i bought the decision
making process at facebook and how that
fits into your lecoultre talked about
the decision-making process at facebook
and how it fits into the corporate
culture really depends on the decision
you know i think that if you code you
know that you make decisions with every
line of code that you write and so
facebook is an environment that has the
expectation that everybody is going to
be making a lot of decisions and so our
job as a management team is actually to
plug every individual into as much
information as possible about what's
going on so that everybody can make the
very best decisions it's a very
distributed decision-making environment
and and Facebook takes that a little bit
that sounds like pretty good thy sons
mom and apple pie right but Facebook
takes it a little bit to an extreme in
the sense of we've worked very very hard
to avoid to give teams small teams a lot
of autonomy to pursue their own destiny
and and so we've kind of eliminated a
few of the checks and balances that are
more standard at at other software
companies so you generally don't go to
other teams like as you get larger more
teams have a stake in what you're doing
but you generally don't go to other
teams and ask their permission you
generally build stuff and test it and
then if that manifests as problems for
someone else then you work it out and
fix it and so I like to say it's a it's
a try-catch model of decision-making not
an if then and so that that has for the
most part served is very very well
because it means that just people
operate a lot faster can we move a lot
faster and even if we're heading in the
wrong direction we figure that out and
course correct faster tonight just ask
you how involved is a senior management
like mark in decisions that are very
granular you know please we know of
companies that have a tremendous amount
of tops down control you never you know
if a button gets changed in color you
know the most senior person is looking
and saying I'd rather have it blue then
yellow you know how involved is mark in
the all of those decisions mark will
definitely give you advice about pixels
and when I say advice I mean make
decisions so mark mark has organized the
company so he can spend the bulk of his
time on product and product strategy
and and he is very able lieutenants that
allow him to do that and he basically
has set up his calendar so that each day
of the week has a theme and the theme is
one of the the department so one day
might be mobile one day might be
platform when they might be you know
whatever and then there will be a block
of four hours and just teams rotate
through that block and and just present
stuff to him and talk stuff through with
him and it's amazing because he's
probably the most gifted product thinker
in the company and and maybe in the
valley maybe in the world that's
probably stretching it but certainly in
our space and he and so like having a
half an hour of his time is just like
amazing and but it's you do have to
learn because he can operate it so many
layers of abstraction at once like
sometimes you know he will say like yeah
that's not going to work I think we
should try it this way and you have to
kind of unpack and figure out like is it
your CEO is he wearing a CEO hat when
he's giving you that feedback and that's
because of strategy and how you're going
to impinge on some other part of the
product or is that or is he wearing his
designer hat or his PM hat which is
about how users going to receive the
feature or how it looks and and he will
and he will dump between those layers of
abstraction and you just have to try to
follow him I mean and and just make the
most of it make the most of every second
of his time that you get so yes he will
be very involved and and he has
structured his time to be involved but
he he can only pay attention to so many
things at a time too and so there if
he's not paying attention like he
doesn't expect you to sit around and
wait for him yeah he expects you to run
forward actually well he's not looking
and if he sort of comes back to you a
month later and finds that you haven't
moved from where he left you he'll be
pretty disappointed right questions back
there please um I think Facebook's
culture move fast and break things is
really admirable but at the same time I
think that the average user Facebook
hasn't really changed that much in the
past few years you know it's photos its
chatted status so I'm wondering how much
the kind of culture of building things
that's focused around building new
things at Facebook versus changing and
improving what's already there um that's
a good question the question is move
fast and break things is admirable but
it seems like Facebook hasn't actually
changed that much in the last couple
years so how much is it incremental
versus sort of big new disruptive things
we certainly feel like we've changed a
lot in the last few years
I think we've have sort of drastically
improved on things like photos and
messaging and and we've tried in a lot
of ways to drastically improve we've
we've tried to new you is for the news
feed which is one of the boulder things
that we do because changing the homepage
always makes people mad actually one of
the biggest places where we've innovated
a lot is in our mobile technology stack
and how we're delivering mobile products
and and I think actually the you know I
don't know if you've had a chance to try
it yet because it only runs on a few
android phones so far but we delivered a
product called facebook home which is a
really social take on the phone
experience and it sort of takes the
phone and it turns us on its head and
puts humans at the center of the phone
experience and tasks makes them more
secondary I think we feel like that was
pretty pretty innovative and you know is
still very much 1 point 0 and has a lot
of work that needs to be done but I
think we we feel like we we tried
something big there and we feel good
about it so I you know I do think it's a
good question because we have got to
always sort of push to do some of both
right we are serving a billion users and
so you know in the one hand we don't
want to neglect them we want to keep
sort of and we don't want to take
anything for granted we don't to feel
like okay we can ignore photos now we've
been there and done that because you
know photos upstart could come out of
nowhere and eat our lunch if we're not
kind of constantly striving to make the
photos experience better so I don't know
yeah I think we just try to do both yes
nice things be free mobile what are the
next big things in mobile well Facebook
home I think will be the next big thing
we haven't yet done it I mean we've
shipped the first iteration and and from
here we have to iterate until it's
really awesome you know the other
interesting thing about mobile is that a
mobile growths enormous a lot of it is
happening in the developing world and so
users are flooding onto smartphones
the next three years we're gonna have
orders of magnitude more smartphone
users than we've had in the past but the
interesting thing is the smartphone that
those folks in Latin America and Asia
and Africa the smartphone they're going
to be using it's going to be a
gingerbread phone it's like a three year
old version of Android and so I actually
think that race there is not who can do
like the snazziest richest craziest
feature on mobile it's actually who can
deliver the most streamlined speedy
lightweight light touch smooth
experience on a very low end low-power
device and you got to be conflict in
this country data is basically I mean
you pay for your data plan but then once
you've paid for your plan you don't
think hard about how much data you're
using when you pay by the minute went
like that when data is as large a part
of the spend as it is in in parts of the
developing world you know you you're
pretty like you know if we do over
fetching in the news feed in the US it
just doesn't matter too much like we
send a few extra stories so that your
feed loads faster you know it's slightly
less of optimal you don't really care
what happens in Africa like we're
costing some our users money when we
send too much data so so thinking about
how to how to do that and then we just
think about phones as the mechanism by
which a whole next set of billions of
people are going to get online and are
going to get on facebook because frankly
lots of people going to have smartphones
and feature phones that have never and
will never have a computer and so what
is an entirely mobile-centric facebook
experience look like that isn't a second
screen device a second device in
addition to your laptop so those are
things for thinking really hard about
can I ask you a question about privacy
yes I'm sure nobody in this room cares
about privacy right
I mean this is always an issue about
what people put on facebook and how how
other who gets to see it and how that
information gets used I think a lot of
people look I've had many many
conversations with people who were
extremely conflicted because they so
want you have to have this social
experience it they're drawn to it and
then they're also afraid of that yes
they're afraid about when I put
something out there that feels really
personal yeah who's gonna see it how is
it someone going to monetize that yes
can be reshard exactly yeah I'm good I
want it yep I think that's I don't want
to say that's AI think it's really hard
I think there are no textbook answers I
actually think it's one of the most
fascinating product challenges that
Facebook has and I think most other
companies have not bellied up to that
challenge fundamentally right most you
know most of the products that we think
of as social networking like a Twitter
or Pinterest or even an Instagram have
an all public model there is no privacy
model you go in knowing that whatever
you put on there is public for all to
see and and I think Facebook is
different and that we are trying to
create a private or a semi-private
sharing model where you can control the
audience and that's like a really
difficult thing to do and and it's very
hard to hit the sweet spot between what
will people understand what's usable
what's easy every time we sort of try to
dial up and give lots of privacy
settings we find ourselves in this black
in this quagmire where you know we've
given users controls that they don't
want or can't use or the paralyzed them
and so I think that it's just a space
where we need to continue to innovate
and and I think you know others have
tried innovating the space I think and
have figured out that like oh it's not
that Facebook is dumb or ill-intentioned
it's actually that this is really hard
this one of like a very sort of
fundamental hard design problem how to
help people understand the difference
between audience and distribution how to
help people understand who sees what and
I you know I think we've just got to
keep trying and and I think to the
extent we are successful we create value
for our users that they will see you in
the world I will say I think sometimes
it's overblown we do surveys like
a large proportion of our users use the
privacy settings the idea that somehow
like the unwashed masses just don't know
how to use Facebook and don't know how
to use the privacy controls that's
actually meaningfully not true you like
how many of you in here have never
changed the privacy defaults on Facebook
right all right so that was like one
person so how many have changed the
privacy defaults on faces every all
right like how many of you have never
used Facebook okay one two three all
right it's good i'm counting so I think
there's your answer right like I think
she actually people are quite savvy they
do care very much about privacy and that
means it's one of the most important
features that we have and it's one of
the most important products that we have
and it's something that we're I think
we're just not done innovating but it's
you know it's not that we aren't trying
it's that it's hard great that they're
mmm question is how is Facebook's
culture changed since the IPO and the
answer I think surprisingly is that it
has not very much this is actually my
third IPO that first thing on the
company I worked for in Texas win IPO
VMware of course when I pol I was there
sort of twice actually and now Facebook
and I think the difference and and the
IPO caused real change at those earlier
two companies and not so much at
Facebook I think part of it is that
Facebook was simply larger and more
mature I think Facebook's really pretty
unique in how long we waited to go
public and so we were pretty gelled as a
culture as an organization as an
executive team I think that I you know
honestly there had been because of that
long wait there had also been a number
of opportunities for employees to sell
equity on the private equity market and
so there were a set of people who
already had great wealth from from
facebook equity and so it wasn't like
sort of overnight people started phoning
in I also think actually we have
optimized for hiring people who you know
are not there for the paycheck I mean we
it's a it's a thing it's a company that
handsomely compensates people but we're
trying to hire people who really care
about what they're building and who are
at Facebook for the opportunity to touch
a billion people and and to make stuff
for them and and we get to keep doing
that and that hasn't changed i want to
say the milestone of hitting a billion
users actually got as big or bigger
hoopla then then the IPO itself so i
think we were really worried about that
and actually it's been kind of a big
deal yes Facebook's engineering is very
central in Silicon Valley especially
compared to other companies that have
local engineering centers around the
world so what's Facebook's approach to a
Silicon Valley or central engineering
versus having local development centers
around the world especially regarding
proliferation Facebook's culture which
is a strong bond what's Facebook's a
question is what's Facebook cooks
approach to regional development centers
we're very Silicon Valley eccentric
especially in contrast to other tech
companies this is true we have only
three other engineering offices outside
of the Bay Area one in Seattle one in
New York and one in London the New York
and London ones are pretty new and we
are looking to grow those all four of
those sites but I would definitely say
that we would rather have a few large
sites than many small sites it is very
clear to us that working across long
distances Geographic distances is just
hard because making software is
fundamentally a team sport there is no
software or significance ever that has
been built by a single person acting
alone you know Facebook itself like you
know mark and listed his roommates
within a week right and and so you're
and this is one of the areas in which
college will kind of mislead you
actually because you're taking a lot of
these CS classes where's actually
cheating to get help from somebody else
and then in real life what we expect you
to do is get help from other people and
it's really hard to collaborate with
someone who you can't look in the eye to
resolve a dispute or or just a
miscommunication and it is really really
hard to communicate with someone
who is in a distant time zone from you
where you're overlapping hours of
awakeness are not that many so she a
ttle was our first remote office and we
deliberately it's the training wheels of
remote offices all right it's like exact
same time zone and it's like a two-hour
flight so you can get up there for a day
trip if you have to and and and and
that's that our strategy is basically to
go slow to travel a lot between offices
to throw lots of money at all the parts
you can throw money at like having
really good bc equipment it's readily
available but we just want to see it be
super successful first in the in the
places where at what we don't ever want
to do is have an office in a region for
the sake of saving money we will just
never hire an engineer like that that
just won't happen so the the region's I
mean I Seattle New York and London are
obviously not low-class locations we're
there so we can bring more talent to the
company but i think you know we're aware
that like working in at a distance from
headquarters is hard and we need to do
more to support the folks in those
offices is it important to have offices
in other places for just regional
specializations so that you understand
your customers in different parts of the
world where do you find that you can
divide by 0 i feel like i should say yes
to that but honestly no we actually did
throw a few engineers into Japan we
found Japan a really hard market to
crack and and people just were using
their phones in very different ways and
reasons wanted to use social networks in
very different ways and so we did
establish a small Japanese engineering
team and product team around really
cracking into Japan that's the one
country where we've ever had to do that
I think for whatever reason Facebook
just connecting and sharing with other
human beings has ended up being kind of
a universal value proposition like I you
know if I didn't see it myself I would
have said it's impossible to make one
piece of software that is used by so
many people of so many you know from so
many walks of life but no we have not
needed to sort of physically visit every
region of the world to develop product
for the whole world great question
the early stage visions of success in
facebook cool quantify forgiveness he is
head of iron p-bass place I can do a
deeper quantification hmm how do we
measure success this is an excellent
excellent question we are a very metrics
driven company it's actually quite
interesting because we're sort of a
vision like company but also a metrics
light company we mix both and as a
product team you'll always have two sets
of goals you'll have some that are just
milestone goals they're just like we're
going to do X because we believe in X
and we're going to deliver it we're
going to launch it and there's a user
usually goals about launching a new
product and then you have a whole bunch
of metrics that you are tracking and
that you are trying to drive up and to
the right and and it very much depends
on the product so you know Facebook as a
whole used to measure monthly active
users now we're measuring now we pay
more close attention to things like
daily active users or a metric that's
even harder which is l six of seven
which a term we made up which measures
how many people are coming back to
facebook at least six out of seven days
of the week and that's an actually even
more difficult number to reach than
daily active users it's a smaller number
than daily active users but still a
large absolute number and then it breaks
up team by team so the photos team will
have goals we have had different types
of goals we've had goals around a volume
of photo tags or volume of photos we
have goals around the number of people
participation rate the number of daily
active or weekly active people uploading
photos photos / uploaders messaging
similarly has goals along those lines
participation rate we're probably more
interested in reaching spread than
volume per user I'm more interested in
40 people uploading a photo each than I
am in one person uploading 40 photos but
it differs at different points in time
newsfeed we spend a lot of time thinking
about clicks likes and comments as
measures of engagement and we also
measure time spent that's a that's a big
one for us and in on mobile we're
looking at more quality measures we're
looking at things like crash rate memory
can
Shin star ratings in the Play Store in
the app store and but but i will say
that a lot of the time when it comes
back to decision making about product
features we're very often more metrics
led than I think outsiders realize a lot
of the times when we're trying to decide
to go one way or another and you sort of
sit out there and scratch your head and
go Facebook why did you do that it's
because we tested both options on our
users and we figured out which one drove
the metrics up more and and we have this
very interesting philosophical debate
inside Facebook often which is how do we
know we're really doing the right thing
for users and and I think that one thing
we do deeply believe is that ultimately
we can't be too didactic we have to be a
little humble about how people use to
choose the site and if people use the
site to share funny cat videos then you
know it's not quite hard place to sit in
judgment on that and to decide that like
that's bad but baby announcements are
good or they definitely probably people
in this room probably people you know
would say baby announcements are bad and
funny cat videos are good at college
students maybe you have different values
but i think that at the end of the day
we look ourselves in the eyes and say
more people spending more time on the
site means we're creating more value for
our users and if we're not doing that
then we're failing our users and if we
are doing that then we're probably doing
right by them and and that makes certain
things tricky especially when we get
really conflicting like when on the one
hand like your gut are your intuition or
even what people say with their words is
telling you go this way and then where
people are spending time on the site is
going a different way and I think you've
got to kind of let go of your ego and
and say the users actually are not
children they're operating in their own
best interests and if what we were doing
was sort of really bad or is like a
guilty pleasure and sucking them in like
that doesn't keep that doesn't retain
users over time right like you know if
you create an addictive experience that
that really sucks a lot of time out of
people but it's ultimately like bad for
them to leave they won't stay with you
like I really think people are adults
and I and so I think you know if we were
out to sort of you know create
experiences when we create experiences
that are bad for our users
it's very visible they stopped coming
back they spend less time they leave and
so you know we really you know I think
we really have every incentive in the
world to just deliver a lot of value to
our users and at the end of the day the
fact that we can measure it the fact
that we can see hey I ship this feature
or I fixed these crashes and now users
are able to spend more time like you you
get that very it's like a it's like a
hit it's like you you you did something
great for them and you can see the
numbers I'm sure you'll agree with this
was absolutely fascinating please join
me and thank you Jocelyn
you